[Music]
primary business of hos Arthur's
advertising implementation so when a
brand goes for a big global market we
take the original creative idea and we
translate it into 30 or 40 languages as
arthur sparta w PP w PP contains
multiple large global creative agencies
and the idea was to connect all the WPP
creative agencies and their studios into
the Hogarth network so that we could
work units of acetals way if you think
about 1/32 TV commercials we probably
make 300 versions so there's a massive
pressure on our production storage to
hold this stuff so we need a really
efficient way of uploading into some
sort of archival value and I think we're
now running about five petabytes so it
is important to have an archiving system
that's responsive and quick that allows
you to retrieve the material quickly but
also allows you to retrieve just the
bits that you want those constraints
meant that we really need to look for
some sort of disk based archiving system
clevis a starfruit being really
cost-effective and and really quick and
actually the really important part is
distributed sort of single namespace for
storage so you could physically
distribute the closet elements into
multiple data centers but make holding
periods as one storage pool that anybody
can access in fact we just bought a
whole bunch more that were safe out of
like a few weeks ago and we're currently
installing I think another 1.7 petabytes
of the stuff and you know the company's
been really responsive and bringing
people to help us install that making
sure the configurations correct the
system actually has never gone wrong